yeah hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing the yardbird being a one hundred
twenty percent a point rating favorite
that's kind of unusual oops okay so we
have the old Indian I place that quite a
bit very early b5 haha interesting hmm
it's not cancelled
jan 2 something something to be done
about this yeah c5 quite often is a is a
way to let's do that lets the matter
it's very early it's very early c5 but
maybe dual do so what do we have now if
I td6 Bishop g5 ok I don't know I'm kind
of falling behind time wise and so have
to speed up a little bit
it looks a lot like some kind of semis
laughs very weird kind of structural
transposition so what is he doing here
let's let's take 94 for night f 59 f 5
is somewhat annoying really in
combination with the bishop 1g5 so
curious what happens next yeah I guess
he really has this reading damaged quite
a bit always up and down minus 6 that's
not so great recent games are really
lost a lot against them you're taking
each to but usually not something do i
do I need to worry about this is what
I'm trying to say and there's no
particular reason to give him that power
g3 is kind of useful move anyway as it
protects f4 and so on ok so i can take
them i think i will do that and now
about Queen d2 queen age 6 it's a very
every standard looking plan yeah so if i
go quincy one you go may go to f8 I
guess
going to be three threatens night h6
this is also not bad let's do this tween
is not bad there and on see if I they
always have 95 it's quite useful so he
says I cannot do that that's interesting
night age six taking their queen age
King age 6 hmm isn't that dangerous so
I'm checking king g 7i can also take on
a seven with and night yeah I mean this
is simple but probably not bad so if i
take f7 with the Queen let's just check
this but I don't see a great way to play
then so i'm just taking this why not
looking at da 26 and now i can just take
that bishop or yeah let's do that and
then look to you one which one don't
know maybe this one so i got one pawn
out of this and a decent position let's
see what now is before move maybe there
should be six something that you might
try ok i'm going to stop the beef on
before the moment it's a bit slow but i
don't think and it can do much about it
you should be three okay i'm going over
to e3 with the Queen no problem ready
they matter f4 actually this this could
be a problem f4 and then 95 and I'm
probably playing this a bit too this is
not very harmonious I always got f400
annoying 95 coming very stupid what I
did here but well the position is still
good I think but didn't feel very
necessary
imminent as we know from horror games
and he's excellent and just time money
trying to to swindle winds out of Los
pollutions swindle or whatever you want
to call it kids come with that don't
really want to trade i mean my king is
safer here until five was a very nice
move that might come cover stone opens
the long diagonal but currently I don't
really see how I even answers book takes
26
I can take twice but I think you sire
should also be pretty good just opening
this diagonal Bishop takes 26 is pretty
serious
Black Rose I'm okay I'm glad to have
that one that that game i think recently
I really lost quite a bit against even
though it wasn't entirely convincing
yeah okay so it was a strange move on
with that very early b 5 i'm not sure if
c5 is really the way to to to play or if
something slowish is in order i gave
three years um okay i wanted to do do
something specific against this not just
play a normal position where you gotta
be five the idea of this move is if he
takes here 90s is really good this is
hanging and something like this is what
I saw and well this is very very
dangerous okay the computer actually
says wide wins outright I didn't see
that but I saw that it is dangerous I
mean it's got nothing developed it must
be dangerous so this is kind of routes
out ed for and if he takes here this is
very good for a white of course I mean
this is kind of coops unplayable again
he has nothing developed and moved tons
of pawns okay this is probably right
then no I taken in this so I'm not quite
sure it doesn't really feel like a
refutation this move yeah i don't i
don't think this is so great to be
honest this is fields better provide it
wasn't sure if he really has to do that
the engine also just gives castles but i
can do the same thing but it's not as a
big of a problem as this is covered i
mean something like this shouldn't be so
bad and my computer says equal
yeah I know this is not easy to play
it's not easy to play for black that
Bishop takes i have 6 g takes f6 is
dangerous ok yeah the computers i played
this this is some simple move the
Energon plays this and wins directly and
to be honest I didn't really see that
this hangs with check check I was just
thinking okay it's not necessary blah
blah blah but it is just strong if he
cancels now I'm just going G 3m and pick
up that piece and if he moves it away
Chad I 27 I mean this is this is kind of
sad for black yeah how's that that would
have been pretty good Maurice video kg
three seems to keep an edge but it's not
as convincing yeah I'm here I mean this
is learn look 60 this looks very normal
intending here but he goes back and well
maybe I can go here this is actually a
good idea looking at some sensitive
squares but I don't think this is bad
really queen bee three yeah and I
thought Bishop f8 now I think you just
you just blundered that check the aquine
teacher doesn't seem to be convincing
yeah I did see a continuation but the
computer did doesn't see one either so
probably that was right I'm kind of
happy up to this point but now you're a
3 and stuff this this wasn't a good idea
what gives gives gives him some hope
queen before it's also better now than
this
yeah the computer still gives me a
pretty big advantage but it's itself
felt wrong what I did him I don't know
man this is kind of a sad move but I
felt a little bit panicky with one
minute ten down and him getting some
kind of initiative this is the engine
suggestion just pinning that night now
computer just wants to do this it feel
feels kind of awkward to this pin but
well I have f3 and everything else fails
and Queen c3 check of courses an idea
hmm yeah that's fields thats that's good
that is a that was somewhat Passover and
now I yeah this isn't actually a mistake
Queen takes us better and the computer
gives a black adequate compensation for
the phone there i miss played that but
here check it kind of turns around again
after you took with a notice this is
dangerous all 93 would have been much
better now misty five here going for
this but okay I wanted to speed up when
I have up to 60 tactics tactics tactics
rookie 60 chat wins outright hmm not
good no 26 I should see really yes sir
that's the difference really between
tactics puzzle and tactic in an actual
game of chess where you simply I mean if
you know there is a tactic and
have like even a couple of seconds you
will see 96 as its kind of the only move
that the sketch anything but in the
actual game sometimes you just function
differently now this disposal km there I
can take here twice but I wasn't
entirely sure because I'm not
threatening anything yet okay after this
is not as clear and then he five is
better I mean you cannot take ready and
what is his move then the engine gives
this one again I have to take with the
rook I didn't see that line but it seems
to work well here assigned a bit early I
mean okay maybe he didn't see the move
Queen d2 I mean I also didn't see this
till makes things kind of difficult for
me nah interesting ok I hope you like
the game thanks for watching